another vaccine is now available in
britain but the covid crisis there is
worsening
prime minister boris johnson has
announced a new nationwide lockdown
trying to stop a fast-moving strain of
the coronavirus that's thought to be 70
percent more
contagious holly williams is in london
holly good morning
good morning well it'll be similar to
the lockdown at the height of the
pandemic last year
following a surge in new cases here
including a record of nearly 60 000
cases just yesterday
but some scientists say they're much
more worried about
yet another new strain of the virus
that's been detected in south africa
as i speak to you tonight our hospitals
are under more pressure from kovid
than at any time since the start of the
pandemic
there were more than 26 000 people with
covert in hospitals in england on monday
40 higher than the worst numbers back in
the spring
overwhelming healthcare workers and
forcing one
hospital to postpone cancer surgeries
it's my first the first monday after
christmas and new years and it's been
one of the worst shifts of my entire
life
annabelle sharma was admitted with her
mother 24 hours later
her mother passed away it's literally
just torn my family into tiny pieces
all non-essential shops will be forced
to shut and schools will stay
closed until at least the middle of
february
but scientists say the new variant in
the uk
is less concerning than another strain
of covid
that's been detected in south africa the
south african variant is the one that is
making the hair in the back of my neck
stand up cbs news medical contributor dr
david
agus told us the south african strain
has more mutations to its spike protein
which functions like a key opening the
door to human cells
and there are fears that could make
vaccines less effective
it'll take another two to three weeks to
understand the immune responses with the
current vaccines
and until then we are very very scared
is the south african variant already in
the us do you think
the true answer is we just don't know if
it's here in the u.s
my gut is probably is here in the united
states
to make limited supplies of vaccines
here in the uk go further
they've taken the controversial decision
to give more people the first shot
but then make them wait twelve weeks
instead of three for the second shot
dr aegis told us it's a quote brilliant
decision because it could give
more people at least partial immunity
gail holly williams reporting from
london thank you